Nằm giúp học sinh, chăm mẹ học sinh sách nhận nhẹ học vào lốc mùi chút học phụ thông năm 2018,
đến 2020, 2020, nhanh trong và chính sách, sự giá dụp ở đầu tạo hàng đổi hướng
sẵn quy trình sách nhận nhẹ học sinh và lốc mùi nằm học 2020, 2020,
sự giá dụp ở đầu tạo hàng đổi cho biết thi sinh có thể sách nhận nhẹ học theo hình thức chức tiếp,
đến trường nơi có quyền vào chú tuyền, hoặc chực tuyến, thông qua cộng thông tin tuyền sinh đầu cấp của thành phố hàng đổi,
các mức thực hiện sách nhận nhẹ học chực tuyến như sau, mức một chi cập cộng thông tin tuyền sinh đầu các của thành phố hàng đổi,
12, trọn đăng ký tuyền sinh trọn tuyền sinh và lốc mùi chút học phụ thông công lập năm 2018,
đến 2020, 2020, mức bà, nhẹp má học sinh, má định dành chiến cơ sở giữ liệu ngày giáo dụp ở đáng tạo,
má định dành và mật khẩu đã được chương trung học cơ sở cấp cho học sinh của ý cấp trước đó, mật khẩu, và vào ui tìm kiếm,
mức bún, trọn trường sách nhận nhẹ học vào lốc mùi theo kết quả trung tự nguyện vào đăng ký vào lốc mùi.
Bước năm, kìm chả bộ dung các thông tin vệ ra đình, thông tin linh hệ lưu ý số địa thoại linh hệ,
sau đó nhẹp má bảo vệ, tích cảm kết khai bảo thông tin và nhấn sách nhận,
mức sấu, hệ thống nhìn thị giáo dịch sách nhận thông tin, học sinh kìm chả nhấn vệ đăng ký.
Bước bây, sách nhận động ý để hoàn thành tháo tác đăng ký vệ vọng.
Lưu ý, học sinh cần ín dây sách nhận nhẹ học để nục càng vô sư tại trường đăng ký nhẹ học.